it was a difficult part of the film to
make it was very physically demanding
i dislocated my ankle some actors like
to hang out in the trailer and let their
stunt doubles and body doubles do all
the heavy lifting
some actors do not the lengths that some
very dedicated actors have gone to in
order to get into a character
are truly unbelievable we might not
believe them if we didn't have the proof
right there on the screen
like what anne hathaway insisted on
doing for real or the insane skill that
margot robbie picked up for suicide
squad
these transformations have to be seen to
be believed
one thing about robbing banks is you're
mostly robbing women so the last thing
you want to be is rude
tom holland's new movie cherry couldn't
be further from spider-man
but it definitely proves what an amazing
and dedicated actor he is
because cherry takes place in distinct
phases of his character's life
it meant that tom had to lose 30 pounds
three months before filming
slowly gain it back only to have to lose
it again because the russo brothers
decided to write in some new scenes at
the last minute
that's a lot of dedication for such a
young actor
it was an amazing experience to make a
film like this
through her roles in euphoria and
malcolm and marie zendaya has shown us
what a brave and emotionally vulnerable
actress she is
but in the greatest showman she went
through an entirely different kind of
painful transformation
in order to perform the incredible
trapeze scenes zendaya endured a ton of
strenuous trapeze and circus training
and i was like take me up but it wasn't
without its accidents
as she and zac efron slammed into each
other over and over again during
practice
when margot robbie showed up on screen
as infamous figure skating olympian
tonya harding she was almost totally
unrecognizable
robbie worked very hard to disappear
into the role as much as she could
training for five months five days a
week four hours a day to learn how to
skate like harding
the ice skating was really hard all
right ice skating was definitely more
painful
on top of that she wore a ton of makeup
prosthetics and some seriously fried 80s
style blonde wigs
her dedication was so intense that she
wound up with a herniated disc in her
spine by the end of it
and if you think that was the only time
that margot robbie risked her life for a
role well
you don't know margo something tells me
a whole lot of people are about to die
in order to film the terrifying
underwater car accident scene from
suicide squad
the actress went into training with a
free diver in order to learn how to hold
her breath
for five minutes at a time he kind of
like meditate underwater
as it turns out anytime water is
involved things get a little bit more
difficult
or in the case of what shaleen woodley
went through while filming the deep
ocean drama adrift
a lot more difficult not only did she
spend almost the entire shoot
soaking wet from head to toe she also
battled some
serious seasickness but she wasn't alone
everyone except the director and
one cameraman got horribly sick from the
waves
those were not fun days and seeing as
how they filmed two hours from shore
starting at 4am and going for 12 hours
we don't blame them
when james mcavoy learned that he was
going to be replacing the iconic sir
patrick stewart as professor charles
xavier in the new x-men movie franchise
he was thrilled so thrilled in fact that
he went
right ahead and shaved his head before
showing up on set we're about to shave
james's hair
this is the moment when he got there
however he found out that his younger
version of professor x was
actually supposed to still have his hair
so
unfortunately for james they had to use
wigs and hair extensions actually glued
onto his head for
almost the entire shoot it's brilliant
it's brilliant robert pattinson is one
of the most recognizable actors
in the entire world and he knew that
would be a problem when it came time to
shoot the safety brothers movie good
time
the movie was filmed on the real streets
of new york city so in order to hide in
plain sight
he shaved his head and moved into a
basement apartment in harlem
getting spotted wasn't actually a big
problem for pattinson in the end
as in order to find his character he
stayed inside with the curtains closed
for
two months lived in this basement
apartment in
harlem and just literally did nothing at
all he also never changed his sheets and
slept in his clothes
denzel washington is undoubtedly one of
the greatest actors of his generation
which is why it must have been
terrifying for the actor who
actually had to waterboard him i said go
for it don't be
don't be afraid i'm not afraid and let's
see what happened
for real that's right during the film
safe house
in a scene where denzel's character is
being tortured for information
the actor insisted that he actually be
waterboarded
he felt that it lent authenticity to the
scene and the character
so despite the director's protests what
you see in the movie is
actually someone waterboarding denzel
washington the first rule of fight club
is
you do not talk about my club brad pitt
has turned in some of the best
performances
ever over the course of his long career
but one of his most famous
is definitely fight club playing the
impossibly cool and incredibly
destructive tyler durden
required a lot of brad including getting
into incredible shape
but pitt didn't want to appear too
perfect so to play a guy who competes in
underground bare-knuckle fights every
night
he actually went to a dentist and had
them chip pieces off of his front teeth
what's it called the imitation game one
of the best performances of benedict
cumberbatch's career is definitely his
appearance as alan turing in the
imitation game
there's a ton of pressure on actors when
they have to play a real-life person
without falling into an over-the-top
impression to fully portray turing
cumberbatch actually had a copy of
turing's 60 year old dentures made
and wore them for the entire shoot
despite how uncomfortable they were
there was just something about him that
immediately really struck a chord for me
when former model charlize theron
appeared on screen as real-life
psychopath eileen warno's
audiences everywhere gasped at how
completely transformed she was
and it wasn't an easy transformation
either in order to take on the famous
eileen
charles wore uncomfortable dentures had
fake tattoos painstakingly painted on
every day
shaved her eyebrows off completely and
had her hair thinned and completely
fried with bleach
why did you do it in the first place for
the money
rooney mara is known for choosing
unconventional roles
and one of her most challenging was
elizabeth salander
in the girl with the dragon tattoo the
dedicated actress spared nothing when
getting into this tough and tortured
character she chopped all of her hair
off
dyed it jet black and bleached her
eyebrows but on top of all of that
she actually got all of lisbeth's
piercings including piercing some
pretty intimate and painful areas
i just wanted to have some just because
it would feel more like i was living
with it
the incredibly committed leonardo
dicaprio gave his absolute
all to the revenant and it shows it's
going to be a very
unique film i think for for years to
come everything you see in the film
dicaprio did for real including sleeping
inside of an animal carcass
eating raw liver and getting sick from
it living
in the freezing cold wading through a
frozen river working in nothing but
frozen bear skins for warmth
and so much more he rightfully claims it
was the hardest thing he has ever done
and we have to wonder if he was even
acting by the end of it or just trying
to survive
in order to play the famed blind
musician ray charles
jamie foxx had to live as a blind person
the production used prosthetics to keep
jaime's eyes fused shut for the entire
duration of the shoot
sometimes upwards of 14 hours a day it
wasn't easy on him either
he suffered panic attacks from not being
able to see and compares the experience
to a jail sentence
i'd lost a lot of weight in a very small
amount in about two weeks
many people have talked about how much
weight anne hathaway lost to play
fantine
in les mis but no one seems to mention
how she insisted upon having her head
shaved for real
on screen in real time that's right
despite the fact that both the director
and costume designer tried to talk her
out of it
and was determined so everything you see
on screen
is totally real for all those who think
acting is an easy job
we hope this helped change your mind we
know we've never had to shave our head
and hold our breath for five minutes at
the office like anne and margo did
how about you thanks for watching see
you next time